christopher hitchens we start off this
program on a new
monday and a new week with the facts
from bethany beach delaware
dear c-span i dearly look forward to the
brothers hitchins
monday morning what a show that will be
let's hope we can't um we don't
disappoint
well peter it says though though i do
think christopher is on the side of the
angels
i fear that peter has a bigger mouth
peter seems to know the devil
and the details so i think he can win an
argument even when he is wrong as hell
well i'm never wrong of course so i
wouldn't know about that but
um of course chris is on the side of a
certain type of angel
um the good old left-wing angels who
seem to be a great deal here um
but i like to think i'm on the side of
the other lot let me start by asking
about bosnia
do you disagree on bosnia what should we
i should hope so um
i've i've become a bit of a born of
fanatic about bosnia over the last
couple of years especially since going
to syria for the summer before last
and um i still believe that it's uh
a genocide in progress and that um
the nerve of outrage about this appears
to have gone dead in this country
um especially in and around the
presidency which is
the only place where proper response
could have come peter hitchens what
about you
well i think it's it's the most amazing
uh
effect of television on modern society
that we're now discussing sending
troops and airplanes to bomb a
a city to bomb the surroundings of a
city and a country
to make ourselves feel happy about
watching the evening news so that we can
feel more relaxed about the
about the atrocities which which are
served up nightly as a way i think of
increasing
of increasing television viewership
there is no policy in this
it's it's purely it's purely a matter of
looking at bosnia saying
it's horrible and then mouthing the
wonderful old phrase something must be
done
that's a good illustration of the
difference between us i'd say
i think in fact the press on this
occasion has done its job
i mean i i had begun after the gulf war
to despair of the press
because it was becoming a megaphone for
the government in this case i think that
a handful of journalists and
correspondents have actually kept the
bosnian story and issue
alive and a good thing too at instance
particularly john burns of the new york
times
but android government of newsday we did
wonderful reporting
from inside the serbian camps and
and from the city of sarajevo itself and
i've restored sort of my
pride in the good old profession what do
you think is going to happen
uh i fear very much that it will come
to airstrikes and that after airstrikes
ground troops and after grand troops
another long
misery solving nothing costing a great
deal of lives
and probably not ending in our lifetimes
but there is obviously always the
possibility won't this time happen but
as long as the pressure is on
there is always the danger that that we
will find ourselves
with military intervention don't you
love it when the right wing suddenly
turns pacifist i mean
they they all now they all talk as if
they're all doves these days when it
comes to bosnia because they don't have
any
what they call vital interests there
there's no oil there
there's no imperial question at stake so
the hell with it all the rest of the
time i mean
one one people like myself who have had
their doubts in the past military
intervention
or the use of force have been arraigned
by this stage as sort of
[ __ ] and appeasers and generally you
know unsolid citizens
i mean i really find the outbreak of
establishment pacifism in and around the
pentagon to be
one of the most cynical things i've ever
seen look if if they're not going to do
this if they're not going to do anything
to stop
the third attempt this century to
destroy physically to destroy a european
minority
then i think there's a very good case
indeed for abolishing the defense budget
but um which i'll be happy to see but if
they're
if they're going to insist on keeping
this kind of level of readiness and
expenditure
it's it's obscene to be overflying
sarajevo every day as we do with
tremendous
technology simply to watch
below uh the slaughter and execution i
think it was the historian ajp taylor
who said that in this century
idealists have killed millions more
people than cynics uh by their belief
that they can
solve things and i feel this may be
another instance of that
which one of uh you is the older
i'm professionally older how much
i wish you'd guessed actually i should
have invited you to guess um well i'll
be 45 in april
i'm feeling every millisecond of it at
the moment oh and i'll be 43 in october
golly what was it like growing up
together i'm combative
combative did you disagree at early at
an early age
yes i think one could say that um but
about the big things and the little
things
what what big things did you just i
don't think i was probably a very good
person who was an older brother
i just didn't think i was much fun in
the give and the take bit
i was always rather you know um
inclined to think i was right you've
been over in this country for the last
six months
uh how does great britain look to you
from this country
well i'm still recovering from the way
it looked from moscow
uh and i'm afraid at the moment it looks
in a very sad case
um a country which when you return from
from
from the soviet union as it then was to
most western countries you feel a sense
of
a weight lifting from your shoulders a
sense of color activity and
and and life but when i came back to
britain i found that there were
rather a lot of alarming echoes of the
the sloth and decay
that i'd found in moscow that we that i
felt far more than i had before
that it was a country in decay and when
i come over here
and see a country which many many
british people look down on as a
as a as a festering place of of crime
and violence and find that how
immensely civilized it is in fact again
it's a snap in the face to any
smug conceptions of of what britain is
like
there's a whole page devoted in newsweek
to the following story getting the kinks
out
britain sex candles tar majors
government
and it leads off by saying stephen
milligan was a rising star in the
british conservative
party a former journalist who spent only
two years in parliament
he was already in line for a ministerial
job still a bachelor at 45
he had dated a string of beautiful women
but apparently something was missing in
millikin's life
he fretted about loneliness and all
consuming demands of politics
he paid one thousand dollars to join a
dating service called
drawing down the moon and last week his
secretary found him dead
on a kitchen table in his london home a
plastic bag over
his head electrical cord coiled loosely
up his body from his ankle to his neck
otherwise he was naked except for a
garter belt in women's stockings there
was no sign of murder
or suicide evidently milligan died when
a kinky sex stunt went horribly wrong
what is what is going on there are other
sex scandals in this story
milligan was a friend of mine we were
exact contemporaries at
university in fact he expelled me from
the oxford union which he was then
president because i
broke up a debate in the course of the
vietnam war um
when the our terrible foreign secretary
came to defend the invasion of cambodia
and i kept up with him on you know
journalistic and political basis for a
while
it's not true by the way by the string
of beautiful women um i don't want to
say anything against him now that he's
dead but
his whole problem was that he was
unlucky with the first sex
um it's it's a sort of
i don't want to make it so i don't say
anything cheap but it's a kind of
revenge on john major's
very second rate policy announced at his
last party conference of proclaiming
family values and back to the basics
as everyone who's followed this kind of
politics knows as soon as you start
doing that
everyone is found in the men's room i
mean it's the same when um
jimmy swaggart starts calling down
hellfire on
sinners you can pretty much set your
watch you know the next thing is going
to happen to jimmy snyder
and i think it's um it can't be
coincidence that the
the the pressure of this kind of public
hypocrisy is too much for
some of its practitioners it also goes
on
this piece to say on january 5th tim
yayo is that the way pronouncing yo
a junior environment minister was forced
to resign after admitting he had
fathered an illegitimate child his
second
as it turned out next the earl i'm sure
i'll mispronounce this
caithness keith mass keith mass the
minister for aviation and shipping
resigned after his wife committed
suicide she was said to be distraught
over their failing marriage and his
affair with another woman
there's another one this morning in the
new york times there's then tory mp
david ashby
denied his wife's charges that he was a
homosexual he had shared a bed with
another man
while on vacation in france these are
tories what's going on the kinsey report
is true which i think probably isn't but
even if any of these statistics have any
relevance at all
there are 650 people in in the house of
commons
and some of them are going to have some
fairly peculiar proclivities and some of
them
are going to commit adultery and frankly
so what if a government says
that it wants to encourage people back
to basics as john major puts it
to make people behave better then
of course you will find embarrassing
instances of people not behaving well it
doesn't undermine
the value of the policy it doesn't
undermine the
damage that it doesn't undermine the
fact that huge damage is being done to
modern societies by divorce illegitimacy
and the things which follow from it
doesn't mean it doesn't see it doesn't
mean they don't have the right to say
look we want to do something about this
just because a few members of parliament
are found in flagranto de litto yes
already lying on the kitchen table in
garter belt this is your
uh this is your paper and you can be
bought here in the united states yes you
can
inside there's a big spread my regrets
by ashdown's lover
uh patty ashdown's lovers i guess this
is a two-year-old story that's known
uh and that uh she first is this the
first time she ever talked
i think i think it's the first time this
one has yes teddy ice down
head of the liberal party what are you
wait is there the
brits look at this kind of a story
differently than the americans
very slightly i think perhaps a little
more um
cynically than americans do um what i
used to notice when i covered politics
in england which i haven't done for a
long time was that
um an old rule of thumb seemed to hold
true with the tories it was always sex
and with labour people it was almost
always money
taking bribes or getting involved in
corrupt business practices
um i don't know if that's still true i
haven't covered it for a while but um
in both in both cases it seemed to me at
least potentially ironic in that the
tories tended to go on more about family
values and labor tended to go on more
about
the evils of capitalism and they were
all caught in the hypocrisy of or other
both court
in the respective hypocrisy of their two
positions beyond that i mean i
don't want to agree with peter any more
than i have to but i mean it's obviously
true you can't have politicians
without this um because they're all made
of the same clay
nor can you have i suppose um this sort
of full-time
dedication to ambition and
self-advancement that was demanded of
someone like stephen milligan for
example without quite a lot of
loneliness and misery
explain uh something over the weekend
i think it was on friday the
conservative political action conference
which met here in washington we carried
had a news conference with a woman by
the name of paula jones
who alleged an involvement or
an incident with the president united
states and this this ended up on the
front page of
saturday's washington times
20 minutes rebuffing his advances
apparently and it says woman accuses
clinton of sexual advances in 1991 this
is the front page of the western times
the story was covered in the washington
post but it was buried in this morning's
front page style section piece
on the conservative political action i
couldn't find it
i'll show you where it was in just a
moment it was it's uh
it's in this story on the front page of
the style here and we can talk about
this but
why the difference from your person both
of your perspectives from different
newspapers and
why is would something like that have
gotten more publicity in
great britain in your paper well it did
uh it was carried
quite in quite quite prominently in my
paper on saturday morning
um it's always amusing to see how much
longer it takes
the washington post and the new york
times to deal with these things
we had the story of the troopers
allegations against the president
in the daily express the the morning
after they appeared on cnn
it took the american press about 36
hours longer to respond to them i think
it's partly because of uh an old british
tradition of being
licentious and published and and prudish
and private we care more about sex
we find it more uh offensive uh for
politicians to
to behave in this way than americans
americans are more interested in money
and i think the white water affair has
done far more damage
to mr clinton in the eyes of most
americans than the sex allegations which
are dismissed and actually
not even known by many people i think
that must be true
um with the with the proviso that um
some americans suspect that the white
water
affair so to say and the the other
allegations are it was in some sense
connected you know
in other words that um the problem with
jennifer flowers was not whether or not
she slept with the president but whether
or not she got a job out of it
and indeed whether or not that's the
reason she lost it so
i think as long as the two uh stories
remain separated in the public mind the
president has a chance of getting away
with both of them but if they should
converge
which i think it's the fear of the
washington times excuse me the
washington post
that they will then the press will look
stupid because the press
convinced itself earlier this year that
it alone was responsible for the death
of vincent foster and handed him and
has been apologizing and back peddling
from the story ever since
so there'd be a lot of climbing down to
be done uh here's a quote from the the
conservative political action conference
in lloyd grove's piece in the washington
post i've never seen so much angst over
a politician
use gop consultant craig shirley who
helped organize the 21st
annual cpac conference republican
strategist david keane head of the
american conservative union cpac's main
sponsor acknowledged that despite
everything public opinion polls still
show the president enjoying
healthy job approval uh i think
people that is conservative activists
are a little perplexed with all the
things that have come out
in recent months about bill clinton kane
remarked this is just another
illustration of why america needs
monarchy
you have to have a schizophrenia uh
when you deal with with the president
here first of all there is this man who
represents the constitution
uh the laws of the nation who represents
america who stands up at the state of
the union speech and and
looks actually quite like ronald reagan
uh who can say or sharks with the best
of them
and then you have the man who is
twisting people's arms behind
behind behind their backs to get them to
vote the right way the man who has made
the most astonishing promises to get
elected
he's the same person and americans have
to think
of a basic down in the mud politician
as a monarch for eight years and they
prefer very much
the monarch to the politician but in the
end the contradiction can sometimes
prove too much
i don't see anyone who's working fleet
street as long as peter has can possibly
be recommending a monarchy to anyone
even the english
um it's you know it's it's uh if you
wanted
to distract people's attention from you
know the tedium
of existence and the um the art of
futility of life and
uh the vulgarity of politics the best
way to do it is not to have the house of
windsor
um as to why the right wing are worried
about clinton i quite see why they're so
well i mean he's basically nicked their
entire wardrobe
this administration in practically every
important respect is what the bush quail
administration would have been
very often most often felt with the same
personnel
clearly this puts the conservatives
extreme right actually in a position of
potential opportunity because they
didn't like bush squad all that much
either
or certainly like the bush bit of it but
for the moment it was
very troubling for gop circles in
general
to see david gergen defending this must
be ironic for them to see
alan greenspan and um uh
all of their head honchos from the last
time effectively
occupying the most public important jobs
and the most private important ones
by the way we've gotten some other faxes
directly related to your
two uh two's appearance here
from phil crossland of youngstown ohio
how would your guest
assess the state of the anglo-american
relationship today
particularly after the royal treatment
our news people and talk show hosts
gave that irish terrorist or patriot
depending on your point of view and the
british reluctance to back air strikes
in bosnia well given that i think that
probably the natural state of our two
countries is one of conflict i think the
relationship is very good
uh we have we have here an extremely
effective embassy
with contacts at the highest levels in
very important areas
such as intelligence we have an enormous
amount of investment here we can
understand each other better than
better than most but underlying our
relations is is a is a deep
division over how the world should be
arranged
uh we came here in 1814 and and burned
down the white house to to
make this point and since then for the
most part
relations have been touchy and everybody
seems to forget that before churchill
came here
in christmas 1941 uh right up to that
point
things were pretty bad and what
friendship we have
was forged by roosevelt and churchill
and we have built upon it and made the
most of it ever since and as
uh douglas heard the foreign secretary
says
it helps us to punch above our weight in
the world to have built in a friendship
with the united states
the adams incident didn't help but i
don't think it damaged
the fundamental goodwill that still
exists here here's what uh this is the
issue that's still
uh good until tomorrow when a new one
comes out the international express
uh and this is jerry adams inside by the
way
um there's a headline that says i had to
challenge this man's glib lies
and there's a picture of your brother uh
and it says
it was left to the daily express to let
millions of americans know the true
colors of jerry adams
our washington correspondent peter
hitchens exposed the shin fein leader
uh his glib lies and phony claims
as a man of peace in a blistering tv
showdown with former new york mayor
edward koch on the fox network's show
street talk
do you agree with what do you think on
the i mean i have to repress the thrill
of pride that there's some
such a pugnacious um member of my family
and uh
someone who's prepared to go against the
stream and be a john bull and all that
but
i think that the british position on
ireland can't be defended um
i think the the injury of partition done
to the irish people
is a terrible one and is the root cause
of the present discontent
i think that the shin fame voice has a
perfect right to be heard and i think it
was perfectly ridiculous
for the british government to attempt to
ban mr adams on making a visit here or
indeed from being heard on the network's
um in england and this is the revenge
for the stupidity of that policy
you've been here too long and you fall
into exactly the same trap
that a lot of american commentators fell
into and imagining this is an issue of
free speech
the reason why jerry adams was banned
from this country
was because the administration
understood that he was connected at the
highest level with terrorism
and i believe it's the case that people
who are connected with terrorism are not
allowed in the united states
suddenly i wish it was true suddenly the
president reversed that policy
and it was never a matter of of free
speech it was a matter straightforwardly
of terrorism and american policy towards
it we were only asking this country
to implement its own policy what would
happen in our newspapers here let's say
the washington post
if this same kind of a picture and
headline of david broder saying i had to
challenge this man's glib lies and what
would
the you've been on this program before
it would be the reaction out there david
wrote a talk more like that i for one
would be delighted but uh
um there's a there is a
a refreshing thing about feed street
even really terrible papers like the
daily express
of which my brother toils i mean tory
rags of the violence die and hugh
um are not hypocritical they don't say
please read the dead express for your
objective view of today's events um
strictly neutral indifferent um
even-handed and so forth
they tell you where they're coming from
and as a result the fleet street
tradition of pros is could do more
robust than the
sort of pretend ideology of objectivity
with which we get the consensus served
up to us here
do uh either one of you uh i mean this
i saw this over the weekend i wanted to
ask both of you about this here's a
picture of
president clinton uh this is a over the
weekend
uh his radio address and you know it's
president lincoln's look first upon this
picture and on this
like hyperion to a sata 185th
birthday of uh abraham lincoln and then
uh
i don't know it's fair to call him
president clinton's nemesis but uh
paul greenbergen who writes from
little rock also invokes the same man
abraham lincoln uh
and at the end of this piece on abraham
lincoln that was published over the
weekend i'm going to drop it so i can
read it
his last paragraph is power is now in
the hands of the pros
and all is supposed to be right in the
world
at so assuring a time why
pause to dwell on this rough figure
behind the now burnished myth
perhaps because it is inescapably as as
danger reoccurs and history continues
americans may yet need of certain
qualities that for one of any better
word
might be called lincolnesque do you all
follow
abraham like oh sure well yes what's he
mean to
people that weren't raised here
extraordinary combination of
saint matter and politician which
doesn't crop up more than about once
every five centuries
uh a very great piece of good fortune
for the united states that
that he was that he was both uh a man
who was essentially good with good
objectives and a man who was capable
of of fighting the battles of politics
with the necessary
cynicism and brutality when it was
called for do you see anything
lincoln asked about bill clinton for
instance i can't rightly say is how i do
no
um i i think of gorvidel's novels
of washington his cycle of historical
novels uh his lincoln is the finest
portrait because it does show someone
who
after all on on many ethical questions
was assumed by the confederacy to be in
a sense one of them or at least of
someone who could possibly be
recuperated
and they consistently underestimated him
they they thought after all he's
basically with us on the issue of
slavery
and he's basically with us on the issue
of territorial expansion they they
they didn't get him at all they didn't
realize there was a point beyond which
he could not be pushed
and i think there was there's an analogy
in my mind between that and the
the way that um some of the european
fascist leadership thought of churchill
they thought well
he's right-wing he's anti-communist
surely we can make a deal with him
they didn't they didn't really uh get
the point it was too late you're gonna
believe this i did not this facts came
in after i showed this last thing but it
says chris
why don't you reform the lincoln brigade
and go seek justice in the balkan civil
war i'll pay your airfare over
doug henry of haverhill new hampshire
perhaps i should explain what lincoln
brigade is for those who or was rather
well no it still is because many of its
old comrades still muster for annual
meetings it was the
detachment of american volunteers that
went to fight on the republican side in
the spanish civil war
it was the first american force in the
field to be commanded by an
african-american in fact
called oliver law i believe was killed
at the battle of haramah
and it became the object of mccarthyite
persecution in the 40s
and 50s um and it was on the list of
band organizations of the attorney
general for a while um
it was closely associated with the
communist party for a bit um
and it i think showed uh some breadth of
mind of such people to take um
honest abe as their um mentor and flag
for the
well five peter hitchcock yes i wish
frankly i mean this will sound absurd
coming from
a pudgy person in his mid-40s such as
myself but i
i very much admire those who have gone
to volunteer their services in bosnia
who are some thousands now and i wish
there were more of them and i wish i had
the nerve to do it myself peter had
since another fact just came in uh from
mark finkelstein of uh
ithaca new york on bosnia does
christopher hitchens find it amusing or
disturbing to be on the same side as
margaret
thatcher you better
all right what do you think we just had
uh lady thatcher here for
in this country for a birthday
celebration of ronald reagan what do you
think of her at this point
well uh it's it's it was it was a moment
of nostalgia
to see them there and to remember how
things were but it it reminded me
it reminded me a bit of um of a problem
which grows
uh for me as i spend more time abroad
reporting
that we use many of us use
foreign countries as a playground for
our consciences
i was guilty of doing this in these
what we called rightly called the evil
empire when it still existed
i believe that there were simple
solutions to the problems
liberal and left-wing people were guilty
of doing it in south africa
and have yet to see the consequences of
what they will but when they do
will not be as pleased as they hoped
they would be and in yugoslavia again we
are finding
a country becoming a playground for
consciences and i i feel that
that mrs thatcher has come to see it as
a place where she has to show
her old spirit of directness toughness
refusal to give in to dictators but
she's mistaken it
she's mistaken it for
for for something completely different
from what it actually is
well i always think it's a shame that
touch and reagan get mentioned in the
same breath because there was a
political opponent of both was still am
i mean i think that uh in point of
character and bearing
she's worth 10 of him at any time um
and i have to say that though i'm
delighted that for example people like
people like that much of the time and no
no i was sort of an admirer of the old
um
battle axe um a grudging admirer i must
say but
in point of fortitude oh there's
something to admire yeah
she's a member of the house of lords do
you normally call it the baroness
to be sure um and yes i think it's good
that she's
uh uh held up
the the west one for a better word to
the humiliation it's inflicting upon
itself
in its complicity in the mass murder in
bosnia yeah uh paul
i hope i'm pronouncing this right ivaska
of las vegas
writes christopher hitchens is one of my
favorite authors i'm enjoying for the
sake of argument
another excellent book notes he says
though i have to keep my trusty
dictionary at the ready have that book
sell
thanks to you um i shouldn't be so
anxious as to flashy on your own show
but uh booknotes is a very well watched
program i discovered i got a huge
mailbag from it
a lot of very interesting phone calls
letters faxes and my publishers tell me
that it's why the book was reprinted it
is by the way still
in fine book stores everywhere for the
sake of argument is the name of it and
i'll ask
peter hitch to react to this my question
is as follows though individual
reporters may be slightly left of center
it seems the major media are
functionally quite right-wing
because of corporate greed and cross
ownership do the hitches
uh hitchens brothers agree and could
they uh
contract uh contrast the situation with
that in great britain
well no i don't agree at all i one of
the most striking things here
is that the only political opinion
available in
the grand newspapers and the major tv
networks is the
political opinion of the guardian
newspaper in britain which is but one
of nine i think i think national
newspapers
uh most of most of which in britain are
quite well to the right of standard
opinion in the united states
to the contrary i mean there is for
example no one with my political
opinions
has a regular column in an american
newspaper
if you want bishop since your question
was phrased personally speaking
um the guardian would be nourished in my
own political opinions there's nothing
no reflection of that in the um
the american press the american press um
i think is probably
in its staffing predominantly liberal
but it's
it's political outlook is conditioned by
the search for consensus um which is a
conservative impulse
we're going to grab a phone call in
about 30 seconds what's the differences
in your lives so far
i mean you were born in malta and you
were born in portsmouth england yes we
were both born in different bits of the
the then contracting but still existent
british empire
portsmouth being its main naval base our
father was a naval officer
and malta being then one of its
semi-colonies in the
mediterranean and we diverged
well i left you know i left the united
kingdom in the early 80s and peter
went to moscow not long after that so we
haven't actually seen each other for
about 10 years
what's it like being here together you
spent much time together here no
but we bump into well it's quite a big
city are you married
yes children yes are they here yes how
many
two no mr hitchens is married how many
kids
um by my second wife i have just had a
lovely daughter called laura antonio
blue hitchens
and by my first wife i have two children
alexander and sophia alexander was once
on this show for two seconds endorsing
governor brown's campaign for the
presidency speaking of governor brown
he's
back on the radio and we'll have a
simulcast of his
program tomorrow night tuesday night
seven o'clock east coast time until nine
out of oakland california
two hours of jerry brown those of you
who follow him or didn't
might be interested in tuning in first
call for our two guests
new orleans louisiana go ahead please
yes i would like to comment
about john major's back to basics policy
and also about peter hitchens suggestion
that
this country needs a monarch i think
that um the back to basics policy as
most of the family values um programs
here in this country are very
discriminatory and very homophobic and i
think that
peter hitchens suggested that we need a
monarch here as ludicrous there's no way
that a monarch could represent the
diversity of this country and i was
totally opposed to george bush and
ronald reagan
accepting titles of knighthood or some
such nonsense from
from england i think that shows they
know they have a very poor understanding
of the history
of the opposition between this country
and and great britain
thanks well perhaps you should have your
own knighthoods then people wouldn't
need to go abroad to get them
um and it it as
as for the other things that you say i i
don't i i never quite understood what
this word homophobic means
it translates as meaning hate um fear of
man but i the the point about back to
basics
is illustrated actually by by some
figures produced by
william bennett which i haven't brought
with me um
what he called the condition of society
index in this country uh the number of
violent crimes between 1960 and 1992
rose from 288 000 to 1932
000. uh the average prison sentence has
gone down from 22 days to eight
um the number of illegitimate births
from 5.3
percent to 29.5 there are some basic
changes
in our societies at the moment in
britain and america
and those basic changes seem to have
brought a great decline in the quality
of people's lives
so if anybody anywhere says that we
should need to go we need to go back to
basics then i for one and prepare to
listen
even if that person is is is found um
with a mistress the following day i
still think he has the right to say it
because it's a very important point
about us
our society and it's not being made
madison heights michigan go ahead please
oh yes i'd like to say uh christopher is
a very good professional journalist and
i
like listening to his commentary thank
you
um my question is do you think that
there's going to be a republican
platform that's comparable to clinton's
now that he's stolen majority of the
issues do you think that they'll stop
pointing the finger and come up with
some issues what do you what do you
predict for the conservatives
well they're in the throes of it at the
moment as you saw if you watched any of
their proceedings over the weekend i
think the temptation will be
to go for something like the william
bennett um agenda
um what sometimes called the social
issues um and to bang the drama about
about public morality it usually does
work because as peter
he has just shown there are always
people prepared to listen when you say
the country's going to the dogs children
don't respect their parents anymore
pretty soon you know dogs will be
throwing buckets of water over us in the
street and so forth um
and we'll all be frightening the horses
um that that seems to work but i think
it's usually a good
a good starter and a bad finisher as a
political issue partly because it is of
course self-satisfied
christopher hitchens has a piece in
vanity fair this month
about oliver north as we take this call
from salt lake city utah
good morning i wanted to ask peter
about the schools in england do they
discriminate against christian students
or the bible or prayer
and also do you have homosexuals
attacking churches over there as they do
here in the united states
thanks well i don't think there's much
homosexual
a a a much of a homosexual offense
against the church and my experience
with the judge of england is that
there's an awful
lot of them in it but the uh the schools
are in
the most appalling mess and it's not
just because of religion officially
there is supposed to be
some kind of religion in schools there's
no separation of church and state
but the teachers and the educational
authorities in the education bureaucracy
have done everything they can in the
past 30 years to remove
any kind of moral content from education
and they've pretty much succeeded
judy robinson of hyattsville maryland
will throw these faxes in from time to
time
she says i am ashamed to be an american
and to pass this nation on to my
children i am watching politicians like
congressman
rostankowski thwart the judicial system
the president united states hide
evidence into corruption
probes and chairman says she says
chairman foley should mean speaker foley
through court action deny the rights of
the voters of washington state to limit
his terms oh it's it seems
to me so obvious that the term
limitation would be an affront to the
constitution
the constitution states the disabilities
um that prevent you or may prevent you
from being elected or being put forward
for election
these do not include having been elected
before and i don't see any reason why
they should it's a completely false
a completely false solution to what is
admittedly a real problem
of the domination by by people of long
tenure of the big committees i'll give
you just
one instance henry gonzalez of texas who
is actually the scourge of corruption
in congress and was the man who
uncovered the ramifications of the
savings and loan scandal in congress for
example
and it's now i'm very glad to say
finally chair of the house banking
committee is going to mountain
an attack on the fastness and secrecy of
the federal reserve
has been re-elected in his district for
i forget now how many congresses but a
very large number
it would be a tragedy if people of his
caliber and experience were removed by
this by this non-sequitur of
german immigrants before judy robinson
has a fit out there let me get the
balance in this because she
hold on peter hitch in just a second she
says i'm ashamed to be an american she
listed the democratic
concerns and she says on the republican
side i have witnessed watergate iran
contra
the snl scandals the keating five and
senator packwood protected by a system
of power and founding fathers never
intended most of the kitchen five for
democrats of course
well i i'm not here to speak for the
republican party um
what about the whole but what about her
whole view is that she
doesn't want to pass this nation onto
her children because she views the whole
system as corrupt
well it's hopeless to expect a political
system to throw up people who are
who are all entirely clean you will find
within it large numbers of people who
are not
but that doesn't mean you should despair
about the system the fact remains it's
immensely preferable to
uh to to the dictatorial systems which
are the alternative
and just try living for two years in the
evil empire and you'll know what i mean
indianapolis for the hitchens brothers
go ahead please thank you for book notes
i just had my history lesson on
economics and everything this morning
good i'm glad you enjoyed it i
especially am a fan of christopher
higgins
he makes me think and things that i had
never
never thought about before i'm always
glad to hear his opinion whether i agree
wholeheartedly with it or not but i'm
usually on your side
um so keep up the good work please thank
you
um i'll try my best are there any more
hitchens like you guys i
can't imagine any more rivals vintage
now are there other brothers and sisters
um i really have a question that i would
like
specifically christopher hitton's
response to it may be kind of off the
wall but i know that hong kong is
getting ready
to revert to the chinese and i wonder
what you might have to say about that
thanks thanks for calling yeah i mean in
1997
i believe it is a date the date that's
become sort of hieroglyphic in the minds
of
people in hong kong quite correctly in
one way
the lease reverts to mainland china from
which hong kong was there next and
detached
um and that's a treaty and should be i
think on it
um but the fact is that since it was
annexed or detached hong kong has
generated its own population and culture
and though it hasn't been a democracy
it's been a british colony with
actually almost no democratic precept at
all it's been in many respects an open
society and the fear is that it will be
handed back
to the senile dictators in in beijing
without any guarantees any any real
guarantees for the
the political or economic freedom or the
freedom to travel and leave
of its inhabitants and that this one of
mrs thatcher's most signal
um failures of nerve given the
reputation she had for standing up to
foreign dictators was her apparent
willingness to roll over and trade hong
kong
for british business concessions in um
in mainland china
um under the present governor
christopher patton who i used slightly
to know
there's been an attempt to say to the
chinese that look we we will insist on
certain minimal democratic
guarantees for the people of hong kong
well i don't think this is being pressed
very
strongly by the current major government
and i think it's a pity because
i think hong kong could be a german
force in the rest of china
um for opening the society up and for
inaugurating a democracy isn't it
wonderful after 60 years
more of anti-colonialism that everyone
is now busy regretting
the departure of the british from one of
their supposedly oppressed colonies
and fearing the arrival of one of the
much
lauded regimes which we were told were
the
banner of progress for so long doesn't
it tell you something about
what a mistake so much of that
anti-colonialism was and doesn't it make
the point
that as you look around the world at so
many of the places where
britain used to rule the
results of britain's departure has been
a decline in
practically every standard you care to
name it no hong kong for heaven's sake
was
imposed on the chinese as part of the
base to um
conduct the opium war did it force the
chinese to take to
take opium it was as you rightly say it
it is a place where freedom exists and
where freedom will almost certainly
cease to exist after july 1997
and if we were to believe the
anti-colonialist propaganda of
of the past 50 or 60 years it would not
be that way around
it's a paradox who owns a daily express
a a company called united newspapers
is this the lord bieber book no uh lord
beaver rook
uh departed long ago and his and his
family i know but did he own it at one
point oh he did yes
uh and this it's the model for the daily
beast in evelyn war's
novel about fleet stream uh inside
there's actually is it the brute
the beast was the mail inside this paper
it said that i got
the international express says save big
only 130 a year
uh what when does this come if you buy
it
too i'm american well i i i buy it at a
little
a deli around the corner from me so then
it turns up on tuesday so i is it
printed in the united states
yes it's printed all over the world now
but there is there is a printing
operation here and i do urge people to
buy it give me any idea how many copies
are sold outside of great britain
the whole the worldwide circulation it
was only founded i think about two years
ago is now 100
000 and rising washington dc you're next
yes good morning gentlemen hi i'd like
to ask if i could
the opinion of your two english
journalists about why there continues to
be such a double standard
deployed in reference to the historical
facts surrounding abraham lincoln
i have three brief points i'd like to
make and
see if they could tell us why they don't
report on them
one is the fact that abraham lincoln
came to power in illinois
as a segregationist if you remember his
pious
peoria speech he whipped up fear in the
people in the midwest
telling them that blacks were going to
be brought into illinois
his peoria speech said he wanted to
preserve the midwest for free white
labor the second point is in article 14
of the illinois state constitution which
was in effect during the war between the
states
it prohibited black people from even
entering illinois
they could not immigrate to illinois why
is that not brought out
and the third point is the homestead act
that mr clinton
was referring to talks about giving away
160
acres to european families as they moved
west
but it completely forgets the fact that
lincoln ordered
a genocide of the native americans
starting with colonel shiverton in
colorado
in order to steal the land from the
native americans so that the federal
government of the northern states
could give away the 160 acres how can
someone that orders a genocide
continually be held up as a good fella
thanks the answer to your last question
is um because history
is a tragedy and not a melodrama
and it's not a morality play in other
words and
um it would be impossible to estimate
any any historic figures other than a
thug if you
evaluated them by the standards of their
of their time
it's true though i'm not a whitewash
lincoln it is certainly true that he ran
more than once
as a segregationist it's certainly true
that he was very reluctant to adopt
the emancipation proclamation didn't
adopt it till it was very late and and
said
openly that if he could have preserved
the union without freeing a single slave
he would rather have done so would have
been
happy to do so and it's also true i
believe that this is disputed
let's say at any rate there's good
evidence to believe that he discussed
the prospect of
removing all african americans from the
united states and resettling them in
slave
colonies probably to be founded in the
american isthmus
um the central mechanisms i mean to say
that's that's argued about it i think
there's good evidence that any rate he
rehearsed the idea
everyone knows what happened to the um
to the american indians of course but
um that's why he's a great historic
figure because he was able to turn on
his own prejudices and his own
upbringing
and many of his own supporters and
decide that not only should the union be
preserved but it should be preserved
um having been cleansed of slavery so
coming from where he did
if you see what i mean that's a historic
achievement lisa chilton of memphis
tennessee faxes
this this to you and and both of you but
we'll give it to peter hitchens first
why should americans consider the
opinions of the british on anything
today when formulating policy
actions in europe if britain was truly
capable of exercising leadership in the
world shouldn't it start in its own
backyard
the quarter-century carnage in ireland
remains a brush fire and now the bosnian
conflict has flared into an inferno
can't european powers put out these
neighborhood blazes well as to whether
we can put out the blazes i i
i have a strong suspicion that nobody
can and and she
rightly points out that 25 years of very
close engagement in ireland
has not produced a solution and if that
isn't a warning about an intervention in
bosnia i don't know what it is
but the point about britain and the
reason why you should listen to us
is that we are and remain your only only
reliable ally in europe
and when it comes down to real
conflict and problems you cannot turn
anywhere else
for for for reliable support various
presidents have tried to make friends
for instance with germany but have found
that
when push came to shove the germans
deserted them
and the common culture which we have
which enables us to speak to each other
much more frankly
than any other two countries in the
world means that that's likely to
continue
las vegas go ahead please uh good
morning good morning
i just wanted to ask uh peter hitchens
did he feel the same way
as he does about jerry adams uh with
nelson mandela's visit a couple of years
ago
after all one person's freedom fighter
is another person's terrorist
right and does he see any contradiction
in that abs absolutely not
nelson mandela was a leader of a
disenfranchised people
whereas jerry adams is the leader of a
small terrorist faction
uh which supports a crime family in a
country where there is universal
suffrage there is no comparison between
the two jerry adams
has supported people who resort to
violence
because he believes it will gain him an
advantage within a democracy
he's poisoned and polluted in democracy
nelson mandela whatever criticisms
anyone may have of him
was fighting against a regime which
sought to suppress him suppress free
speech and was not by any
standards a democracy did you say that
you thought jerry adams was coming back
to this country
i heard that he'd been invited to be the
um grand marshal of the sun patrick's
day parade
in uh san francisco so we'll have to go
through all this again
i i mean i think it's i want to i had a
confrontation with mr as myself in new
york when he was here and i don't just i
don't really dissent from anything that
peter says about him as a person or his
organization i just think that
it's important to remember that there is
in northern ireland and there is also in
the united states a community of people
that believes itself to be the loser
in the irish civil war and the
anglo-irish treaty of 1921 and i think
that
the these people have a historic right
to make that case duluth georgia you're
next yes good morning
hi brian i want to make a couple of
comments uh
the calls you get at times that c-span
doesn't show the conservative point of
view should be very happy
uh that conservative political action
committee in from washington
uh was shown over and over on the
weekend and i never saw
brian and i went to one of the two
brothers of the company that never saw
says this is the united states not
england
just mean-spirited people in all my life
this is not the thing but i saw language
there with that was
degrading disgusting uh cynical about
president clinton everything was
personalized
and i i myself even though i'm a
democrat when when reagan was in and
when bush was in
even though i didn't like their policies
i never called them names i o
and when when we got into the gulf war i
stuck behind my president i don't know
what's going on with the with the
with with the conservative movement
today and another question i want to
make to the
to the other and i forgot your first
peter uh this paula jones this girl you
mentioned if you have a antagonist
who's always on your back he brought up
the draft this
cliff jackson from arkansas he he
brought up
the arkansas uh the arkansas troopers
he he also brought up this paula jones
now if you had
an enemy of yours and kept bringing
things up bringing things up just one
person
there's got to be something wrong and by
the way i saw paula jones on abc
and she said i was harassed in 1991 and
at least he could apologize to me now
what kind i mean
i don't know if you can follow my
viewpoint in other words where do they
get these people all of a sudden and
those troopers by the way were on net
and i called up this paul wyrick who's
head of the
who's head of that station and i asked
the trooper they said were you ever
involved in
an insurance fraud and one brother says
to the and one one
trooper says well yes i have bones in my
neck i broke my neck and i couldn't get
insurance
you must know what that means so i had
to use his name to get it now these are
these undercuts undercuts everything so
i just want to know what your comment in
general what i just said thank you very
much well
the the first point is this there's
nothing wrong with with a bit of name
calling
in in politics it keeps it alive and in
britain we have it
institutionalized twice a week in prime
minister's question time when when the
prime minister of the days is exposed to
a howling zoo
of hostile members of parliament and i
think it it's very healthy
for the political system and we don't
and
this is another point that i make about
about the monarchy we don't have to
respect our politicians as as you do
because
we have a monarch whom we can and have
to respect and therefore we can take
them a little less seriously
and as a result this schizophrenia which
affects american politics is is not is
not our problem
as to as so mr cliff jackson well i see
your point he does seem to
be pursuing his old ex-friend pretty
ruthlessly
but mr clinton is president of the
united states and
what mr jackson is saying about him is
that he has behaved in a disgraceful
fashion
and he is saying it again and again
again until somebody listens
and one can hardly hardly complain in a
democracy
if presidents are criticized your piece
on
ollie north and the vanity fair issue
that's out by the way that has this
cover of
family values with the the trump family
um
i would ask you about uh what what
chances you give ollie north of being
senator
in 1999 in this town
excuse me the piece is about not just
why he shouldn't be a senator
about why he can't possibly be one um it
uh and won't be um i don't think he'll
really even
get the nomination i don't think that
there are enough republicans
in the great state of virginia the home
state of mr jefferson who can overlook
what i've written about in the article
which is
oliver north's involvement in the drug
trade however north um
involved in the taking of hostages and
trading of kidnap victims in beirut
oliver north's attempt to cover up his
mental crack up
his lying his chicanery his petty theft
his portrayal of his friends it's just
not good enough
it makes me feel sort of quite you know
like in favor of conservative values
um you can't have a character that that
shabby and i think the um
republicans of virginia will will
conclude that relatively early on and
spare their party the embarrassment of
having him carry the gop flag by the way
we mentioned that
jerry brown would be on this network on
tuesday night on friday from noon to
three the rush limbaugh show
simulcast from new york we go next to
orlando florida go ahead please
oh well tell rush i'm drinking my orange
juice then
uh brian i mean fellas from england
uh one of the questions i'd like to ask
is uh you talked about
president clinton oh i have another
point after this by the way but
you talked about president clinton's
favorable ratings
would you two talk about the ratings
before the last election in britain when
they thought that labor was going to win
by a landslide
that's how polls are clinton is not
favored in america the press
favors him but not the people and the
next point i'd like to make
when you talk about carnage in the
united states and
um slaughter of the horrifying pictures
in sarajevo that's because cnn
showed you the carnage and slaughter we
were not privy to that information
in waco we had to be three to five miles
away with cameras
when they went into to get the bodies of
these babies and children we did not see
that carnage i guarantee you
mrs reno would not be there neither
would clinton if they saw the carnage
and waco as we saw in sarajevo all right
thank you peter hitchcock i'm i'm glad
to see that the adulation of giant arena
which astonished me at the time is
beginning to fade away
and the the waco trial makes it clear
that
that all was not uh exactly as it should
have been
um but as for the ratings uh yes i
remember that uh that general election
very well
because i was following the labour party
leader neil kinnick around um
some people thought that i was his cliff
jackson um
at the time and the
the polls were not telling the truth but
in in this case
i suspect that uh president clinton is
getting a measure of support i watched
his state of the union speech and i felt
that he had somehow achieved an empathy
with the american people a monarchical
empathy to raise the point again
which will unless a serious scandal in
the next couple of years
carry him through to a second term uh
facts from
nina planck here in washington uh chris
hitchens
uh we miss you at harper's magazine as
washington
editor how long have you been away nice
of people to remember that
um until a year and a half ago i was the
washington editor for harpers and i used
to do a
column called capital letter from from
here
and then i was um wooed away by vanity
fair to write the column which i do
every month called cultural elite the
one that i just plugged is
the one by the way how often are you in
the nation and i'm in the nation every
other week economical minority report
you can try and catch that in this prank
if you if you if you liked
gj romano of grants pass oregon any
chance of driving that c-span bus to
texas we've been there
and stopping at the trial of the
davidians i'm getting overloaded on the
hardigan
on the harding kerrigan issue and i sure
would like some more information about
17 children under the age of 10
uh could be torched by our employees uh
now this is news the bus is going to
order or actually it's going to
cape canaveral today sorry that we can't
divert to texas
denver you're next yes brian sure like
mondays and fridays with the reporters
thanks i have a question from mr
christopher hitchens
i've watched him many times on different
tv
forums or talk whatever and so forth and
i he speaks
beautifully and he has a very fine mind
i just wonder if there's no
it's not going to go on being this good
i can tell
i just wonder if there's anything he
obviously doesn't like anything about
britain i just wonder if there's
anything he likes about america
i fail to ever find anything that he
has a favorable impression of i'm sorry
for that
it may just be that i've been on
television only when
the you know things have turned
acidulous enough to invite me on
the uh there's much to my in both
societies what i've argued in my
writing about it i even wrote a book
actually once about the special
relationship saying that i thought
the americans had been rather poisoned
by an attachment to the english class
system and empire
but i think what's been the problem is
we've borrowed the wrong things from one
another
um for example peter just mentioned the
parliamentary question time which was to
which we subject our prime minister i've
always wished
that that would be the case for the
president and the senate and house
indeed
abraham lincoln very nearly did start to
agree to a question time
which c-span has made more popular in
this country and during the civil war
i wish that things about britain like
that were more admired all the
broadcasting standards of the bbc were
more generally
available here or um of the west end
stage or of the national health service
um and as to to the united states it
seems to me i've
made the best testimony i can by
deciding to make it my home
is you raise an american family as you
travel about the city in the country and
people learn that you're christopher
hitchens brother what's the first thing
they say to you
they say aren't you christopher hitchens
his brother and i say no he's my brother
by the way here's a fact from david in
los angeles uh
actually lexor pictures uh do you think
that in the near future before
armageddon
that the us should return to the british
commonwealth of nations
well i didn't know i'm again was was was
that um
that close but uh frankly um i i
wouldn't wish the british commonwealth
of nations on anybody
uh as a as a body of um dictatorships
and
and failed nations is one of the most
depressing international organizations
i've ever stumbled across and i would
advise you to stay
well clear of it with any luck south
africa will rejoin once it um
has its democratic election i think it'd
be a great honor to have president
mandela join the british commonwealth
as to the other matter well cecil rhodes
when he set up those famous scholarships
gave it us the objective of the
scholarship program to recover the
united states for the british empire
so you might want to watch out at the
number of rhodes scholars who've been
smuggled into senior positions by the
clinton administration it's already
double the number that uh president
kennedy employed
uh from last friday's show which uh
michael elliott another brit was here
and
we had um eric martin yesterday and
now you two and last night was bill
emmett this is
britt's weekend here at c-span uh from
last friday's
this is from kitty crouch of plattsburgh
missouri
friday's journalist roundtable the
disqualifier was
an anonymous source how is it different
from deep throat talking about the
document shredding at the rose law firm
um well i do prefer my sources not to be
anonymous especially if they're
about things like that deep throat was a
source of continuous
actual information which could be
checked out it's different from an
anonymous tip-off that
which is its own and sole authority you
agree with that
peter i don't know i think there was
something very peculiar about the
response of the rose law firm which
changed its
statement on the alleged shredding three
times
and i must say i've watched the work
that jerry sieber has done in the
washington times and he's generally been
ahead of the game so i will reserve
judgment on whether
that anonymous source will turn out to
be another deep threat or not
richfield minnesota you're next yes i
wanted to agree with one of the previous
callers about uh
how often that gop conference was run
this weekend i was trying to watch c
spanner i finally quit listening because
they um
oh nasty personal
and i disagree with peter hitchens that
it's all right to call
call names and uh i i believe there's a
plot going out on out here in this
country with the conservatives
because every time the president comes
up in the polls they're out in the
country
digging up something and it's it's just
i just can't believe it what impact do
you think it has on the public at large
are they going along with these things
that are dug up or are they rejecting
them
well i don't know so far it looks like
they're rejecting it
and i certainly hope the american people
are going to be able to see through this
all right thank you peter hitchens yes
well the the the the problem of name
calling
is uh is is one that i addressed that
you
you really should get used to it it
doesn't do any harm but the problem for
conservatives in this country is that
they're in danger of doing what
democrats did during watergate
and imagining that they can ride to pass
simply on the basis of the failure
unpopularity and sleaze of the regime
which they attack
they'd be much better occupied and i
agree with you about this at least
in formulating a policy which would
appeal to the american people and which
would get them back into the white house
and which might conceivably
remove the permanent democratic majority
from the constipated congress which you
suffer under
this article by lloyd grove on the
conservative conference over the weekend
he writes about lisa kennedy montgomery
21 year old
mtv video jock
is chewing college to start a career in
radio where she gained
a following with heavy breathing poetry
sexual sonnets
she calls them about her love fantasy
dan quayle
quote there is dan with the piercing
eyes so blue so
in tone by way of illustration in 1992
she jumped i'm not doing very well with
the poetry reading in 1992 she jumped to
mtv where she hosted 11 30 to 12 30 late
night
uh grunge show are you are you with this
so far alternative nation is what it's
called
conservative guys or babes she argued s
suit wearing hunks
anything you want to comment on so far
yeah i was once the specter of the feast
of the
nick pacquiao the conservative political
action committee conference i had to
open as the sort of the banquo with them
joe sobran and it seems to me that
things have cheered up since the one i
went to which was as stayed as could be
it was a row of suits
lloyd grove says on saturday kennedy was
seated at a place of honor
retired marine lieutenant colonel oliver
norris table when north breezed into the
conference to address the young
american america's foundation a group of
several hundred college kids
he looks like he watches mtv kennedy
ventured eying north
no we don't get much tv the virginia
senate candidate clarified later
but we had a very nice conversation
sick what would you vote for
oliver north if you lived in virginia
and could vote uh
no i don't think so um but i i don't
have any really very strong passions
about it i don't i don't find him as as
disturbing as
some people do because i don't think in
the general run of politics he stands
out as being particularly villainous
southfield michigan go ahead please uh
yeah i'd like to mention also although i
wasn't going to the viciousness of the
conservative conference i think it
started with the merchant of meanness
otherwise known as rush limbaugh by the
way i'm giving up orange juice
i would challenge the gentleman's
comment but it doesn't do any harm
because we used to show a great deal of
respect for the position of the
presidency if nothing else
i mean it was apple pie chevrolet the
presidency automatically by virtue of
his having attained the position
deserves some respect
and that is i think russia became so
rich so quick
by breaking all the rules doing it
deliberately saying i don't have to
respect and i won't
and aren't you people out there just
ready to jump on to
all of these now known as feminazis i
think that word in and of itself is
rather
revealing but that's not really what i
call to say with mr
jackson and peter brock and all of their
charges
i think the reason they're going to be
dismissed is because if they're
connected with brock and jackson
they're automatically questioned in fact
i i watched a rerun about five minutes
ago
and jackson made the comment that
clinton was always obsessed with the
presidency
and he questions the mental stability of
anyone who is obsessed
and i swear if they ever put obsession
in the olympics jackson's got the gold
with his attempts to to have clinton
removed from the presidency one story
i'd like to ask somebody to look into
would be when ronald reagan retired
number one his two million dollar payola
from the japanese which is what i think
costs general motors
half of its salaried workforce but the
other issue is the reagans were given a
home by the friends of reagan
it was in santa barbara where the
uh company that was given the star wars
contract
and that was hughes aircraft and delco
systems
don atwood was vp of general motors
before he became the assistant secretary
of defense
and it was right after that that they
got the star wars contract
and these friends of reagan i'd like to
know who they are
all right thanks mr hitchens well
actually
the friends of reagan is something that
begins before he's even governor i mean
a group of
fairly rich right-wing californian
businessman holmes title um
justin dart if you always decided that
they would pay reagan's bills and use
him as their
sort of smiling front man from then on
and i'm sure the practice continued
and cushioned his retirement and as
always with these things there's nothing
illegal about it and the scandal is what
is taken for granted the only thing i
know about his home
in the santa barbara who didn't mention
is that when he and his wife moved into
it they found that the street number was
six six six which is everyone knows is
the mark of the beast
and because they're both very primitive
and superstitious and astrology guided
and in other ways cretinous they changed
it to 665 and a half
and i think that's far worse than all
the paola put together let's go to
torrance california next go ahead please
oh good morning gentlemen first of all
let me please describe myself as a
raging moderate on by no means
conservative moderation or death
um i want to read a very short passage
from a text on
abnormal psychology and please
understand i'm certainly not
asking you for a clinical diagnosis here
keep in mind um whether or not what you
think i'm reading might relate
to the issue of trust that the american
people
seem to have with our president
the first characteristic is inadequate
conscience development
and lack of anxiety and guilt
anti-social personalities are unable to
understand
and accept ethical values except on a
verbal level
they make glib verbalizations and claims
of adherence to high standards of
morality that have no apparent
connection with their behavior
because this marked discrepancy between
their level of intelligence
and their level of conscience
development they have been referred to
as moral morons peter hitchens
what can i say um are you casting
especially on the president of the
united states i i think i'd probably be
the most unwise of me given the comments
of some earlier callers on on
uh political abuse to agree with you
that this applies to any any major
political figure of our day
there's a ton of facts coming in i have
just finished for the sake of argument
uh it is your book it is motivating
thoughtful exposing a must for all thank
you mr hitchens
uh so that facts got through i was
wondering if it would yeah it did get
through
from i think it's evelyn keys uh there's
another one here though why does vanity
fair have a cover with the trump's
preaching family values when they're
adulterers
and had a bastard child then inside you
blast oliver north as
poor stock for a senator yet he was
cleared of all charges and as far as we
know an upstanding family man
um that's penny clark of alexandria very
good on nothing on the first point i
think the title
of klein's piece saying trump family
values is supposed to be slightly
humorous
um it's a common fallacy to say that
oliver north was cleared he wasn't clear
of any charges the charges um were set
aside on a technicality but they were
not overturned
um on the grounds that they the the
convictions arose from north's own
testimony
which had been immunized before congress
if he says he was clear to the charges
what he's saying is that everything he
said to congress was a lie
which since he said it under oath would
convict him outright of perjury there
and there
don't let people get away with telling
that about north by the way it's simply
not true
um it is true that the courts are
sometimes soft on crime and people get
off on chain of cards and
i'm a staunch conservative in saying
that i think that's a bad thing um
that's it really this woman sent two in
we don't normally do this quickly but
she says two thoughts on russian citrus
commission
vodka and oj hold the oj a day with rush
is a day without sunshine
i would like to give christopher
hitchens an opportunity to remind people
of today's dreadful anniversary that is
salman rusty
thank you you know i was i had tied a
knot in my own uh
handkerchief about this thank you for
whoever that was it's five years ago
today valentine's day that from tehran
came um
the edict or uk's or fatwa as it's known
um
to shia muslims uh whereby the ayatollah
khamenei
presumed moribund fanatic that he was to
sentence a friend of mine and a great
author
to death and since then salman has been
living under what is both a death and a
life sentence
if you go to your bookshop today thanks
to don delillo and various other
generous authors international pen is
putting a
leaflet in many many millions of book
bags reminding people it's beautifully
a beautifully written reminder of what's
happening i would suggest everyone goes
and
rewards an american bookshop today and
um orders a copy of the paperback of the
satanic verses and
tells the ayatollah and his heirs
inheritors and assigns
where to put their fatwa hope well
virginia go ahead please
yes i'd like to make a quick comment to
christopher hitchens or hudson who
talked about oliver north
i am planning to be a delegate for
oliver north of the republican
convention
and the main reason we're going to elect
oliver north from virginia
is just to make the rest of the country
mad we are sick of new york
california new jersey the northeast
washington dc and the rest of the
liberal country
and we're going to send a message we're
not going to put up with it too much
longer before we leave
we left once we'll do it again we're not
going to do it too much longer
all right i hope there are lots more
like you and i hope that everyone
listened to that
peter hitchens in your reaction to that
caller i i did think that the civil war
was over and i didn't realize the issue
was that potent
but i i'd prefer to stay out of it this
is the sort of stuff under the rocks
that north brings out
and i mean i thought that was very
eloquent when you two disagree
what's the number one thing you'll
disagree on politically
well it used to be the soviet union um
and sad to say
um i always remember christopher saying
i think he denies it now
that he didn't care if the red army
watered its horses in hendon which is a
not
not particularly agreeable suburb of
london um
and also telling me that the soviet
constitution of 1936 was a
was a document of great moral force and
i used to mock him for this and indeed i
still do
um now so union is gone i suppose we
could disagree slightly about salman
rushdie
um not just about the quasi of his books
but about the
wonderful paradox again of this man who
spent many years modestly sneering
against the british conservative
government and then found that when he
was in deep
trouble and danger they were the ones
who could be relied upon to protect him
from those who wish to assassinate him
whereas the the left in britain and
particularly the british labour party
deserted him and left him swinging in
the wind how long are you going to be
here in the states
well i'm here on a two-year assignment
um i'd i'd like to be here longer but
uh two years is what is what the paper
says and
that's what i think it'll probably work
out but with newspapers you know it
could even be less
i feel like i should clear my name on
the uh on the red army watering the
horses
it's certainly true that i squall with
peter a lot about it i i regard
and regarded the united states as at
least morally
a co-founder of the cold war and of the
uh and more than a co-founder of the
arms
race i didn't think of the of it as a
battle between democracy and evil empire
and i don't in retrospect think so
either
um on salman i don't think there's any
irony involved in the fact that a
government that he didn't much care for
uh took on the responsibility of
protecting him he has the same right to
say another british citizen to be
guaranteed against um the depredations
of blackmailers and
people who openly offer money for the
procurement of assassination orlando go
ahead please
yeah good morning everybody and happy
valentine's day thanks thank you got a
couple of questions before i get to it i
just want to say i get a kick out of
these people who call up about the nasty
conservatives
remember there's james carville and
george stephanopoulos
but the democrats will have their
tournament c stand and the woman that
called about the feminists being
feminazis
these people really just don't listen to
rush there's only about 25
semi-nazis according to rush and that'll
listen to him for about a month
my first question is i want to know
what's the difference between bob
packwood
what he did about 20 years ago and
clinton and what he's done in the last
12 to 13 years
and i think when clinton talks about the
last 12 years he must be talking about
jennifer flowers mr freudian slip and
sally purdue and
recently paula jones and i think
character is so important and i try to
teach my sons that integrity and honesty
is very important i think it's very sexy
and remember what goes around comes
around
and do you think more papers other than
the new york post
and the washington times will pick up on
vince foster
and all the oddities of his death mr
hitchens
they said which one um look i think
that if you think back on it um john
tower
didn't make it to be secretary of
defense i think it was absolutely
ridiculous to even consider him
a secretary of defense but not because
he was a boozer and a bit of a groper in
fact there's only two good things i knew
about him
uh but those were the only grounds on
which he could have his nomination
arrested or held up
same with clients thomas same with
packwood same with um
innumerable others the question um
with these peculiars is do they connect
to anything else is it is it
anything more general than human frailty
in other words
as with say john f kennedy whose
promiscuity was an aspect of his bad
politics and he was sleeping with a gun
mole who was a mafia girlfriend at the
same time
he was using mafia as a state instrument
of policy in cuba
thus the peccadillo connects to the big
sin and
becomes important to investigate
question with clinton is as i tried to
say before
is his sexual style so to speak related
to the way that he ran arkansas with his
wife as a bit of a racket of sort of
revolving door of
special interests and campaign donors
and favors and has he brought that style
to washington
i think that's a very good question i've
tried to ask it in the nation
and um and i've i've found that the wall
street journal's questions on this have
been very pertinent and some of the ones
in the american spectator also you know
and i'd like to move on from that to the
question of
vincent foster and his very peculiar
death which you mentioned i do hope
that as you suggested other people do
take it up the more i look at it the
more bizarre
it seems and i've been trying for
instance under the freedom
of information act to get documents on
his death for some months
and they have been denied all kinds of
things which should have taken place in
this death haven't
and i very much hope that the major
press takes it up
and it becomes the issue which it ought
to be sonoma california
hi good morning uh good morning to you
english chaps uh i originally called i
wanted to
mention something about the uh the
russian chernobyl
thing but since a couple callers i was
waiting i just want to make a
few comments on that it'll be painless
i'm sure
um i guess you will but
uh christopher i called to give you a
little pat
on the back i've been watching you for a
while and you you seem like you got a
good head on your shoulders like the
other guy said in all that
you seem like a real credit to the
journalistic the
people um i didn't know you had a
brother uh i'm glad to see that
turning out to be a double threat that's
real good
um and brian of course you know
excellent show but on the chernobyl
thing
they have 180 tons of uh plutonium just
you know contaminating the earth and
now we know that there's a submarine uh
leaking in the north atlantic and now
we've just been told there's a submarine
leaking in the middle atlantic
and i'm under the impression that one
gram
of uh plutonium can pollute the entire
ocean
so uh you know i think you guys should
do a little bit more stuff on this
thanks well it's just an illustration
again of of how the soviet union
was an evil empire the incompetence and
sloppiness and sloth of the people in
charge of chernobyl
and the risks taken by the people who
drove the soviet navy's nuclear program
were incredible and the world is
littered with the results of what they
did
without any serious supervision at all
and you're going to be finding more of
it
and if you think that the two
superpowers the united states and the
soviet union were morally equivalent
you'll find in the conduct of their
nuclear program
clear evidence that this was not so
simulcast of jerry brown tuesday night
seven to nine east coast rush limbaugh
friday 12 to three
east coast time ardsley new york go
ahead please yes i have two comments
uh the first comment is regarding cliff
jackson i think he has an unhealthy
obsession with getting the president
i don't know if the fbi is looking in
but i would certainly look into this
man because i think it is so unhealthy
that he would be capable
of killing the president that's my first
comment
and i'm i'm very serious about that i
think it's a completely
unhealthy obsession and the second
comment i have oh christopher i
i just love your writings and i look
forward to getting my vanity fair every
month
um i want to say um
if you would kindly fantasize a little
bit
and go up to 1996
and it's the day after the presidential
election
and president clinton has won
re-election can you fantasize for us and
tell us why the republicans lost it
thanks
um i wouldn't have to fantasize i would
love invitations to fantasize naturally
but i
i wouldn't have to fantasize very much
or free associate very much
to come up with the answer to that the
republicans would have lost because they
would have been defeated by
a moderate republican president um
because that's what i believe the the
clinton goal presidency to be
it's he's attempting to shift the center
of gravity towards something like a
ground coalition of
you know liberal republican and um
conservative democrat and
i think there is a mass constituency for
that sort of politics in this country
and that's why he's
um forgiven so much in the polls for
what has been so far not very exciting
presidency
phil huff of dillon colorado roses are
red violets are blue peter and chris are
cleverness imbued
what if british healthcare at first
there was despair and now it seems
pretty fair should everyone in america
be covered let's go to gonzales
louisiana next we may get to that if we
have time go ahead please yeah look
i want to comment on the politically
correct group here you know they're
always
the liberals who are always
look like they're always voicing their
opinion that if you don't agree with me
you know well then you're wrong and uh
you know
i like rush limbaugh i think he kind of
opens up
you know uh what he has to say he's not
down liberals he's only showing where
they're uh
they always think they're right and as
far as cutting down presidents
they never when ronald reagan first got
in there it was like you know
reaganomics voodoo
reaganomics and they never gave the man
a chance and the same thing with george
bush there's a double standard here
i believe the pr the liberal press i
think is poor journalism nowadays
very poor journalism because number one
it's a one-sided thing
thanks peter christians that goes to
comment
well just just on political correctness
the the the
one i enjoyed most was the los angeles
times
style book for journalists which urged
them that in future they should not use
the word
normal presumably because there is
nothing normal in los angeles anymore
from orlando florida helen park faxes
how much money could the british
treasury say if the royal family was no
longer subsidized by british taxpayers
and would the savings offset the losses
in tourist revenue
probably not um is the answer to the
second question yeah
it's very difficult to find out how much
the royal family costs if anything
because
the royal family owns so much of the of
the country
in the strict sense of real estate as
well as a lot of um
property um that
it's and so much of that is very closely
held the crown of states are very
secretive body not really subject to
parliamentary scrutiny
but those of us who are republicans by
which i mean i think only myself i don't
think i speak for my brother in this
don't think of it as a as an actuarial
or financial question
i mean i would i would be very glad if
there was less tourism you like
the monarchy i think the monarch is
essential and i think it's far cheaper
than the
new air force one which you've just
spent so many millions of dollars on
building
and the question of money isn't isn't
really important the monarchy pays tax
the queen goes around baking palace
turning out the lights to save money
sun city arizona go ahead please i'll
tell him that photo if she asks
sun city you're on the line go ahead no
i got the wrong one hold on here let's
see if we can get
did i miss i did let's go to washington
dc go ahead please
hello it's a delight to get through for
the very first time and i love your
guests they ought to do a regular
hitchins and hitchens program on
c-span or cnbc don't say it twice
uh a couple of callers have talked about
the whole question of cliff jackson and
his pursuit of
bill clinton i think the motivation
comes fro
for a number of us who really see him as
an illegitimate president
and i don't think you have to be
paranoid or anxious to get someone
to get to an issue of justice i think
the way in which
the administration has withheld
information from the public first about
who was on hillary's health care task
force
then about the travel gate then about
vince foster's suicide
it's enough to make you think that
they're not obeying the rules that all
the rest of washington is compelled to
live by
thanks why cliff jackson seems to have
really touched your nerve isn't he
well he was on the panel yeah i
understand i realized but um
and it is there is something very
extraordinary about about very driven
about the guy but i mean look if you
were i was a doctor at the same time as
these guys i didn't know either of them
but suppose i had known someone very
well and thought of him as a very poor
character and then watched him
inexorably rise to be the president i
think i might go around saying look
i i insist on telling you something
about this guy that you may not know it
might well become your cause
i don't think mr jackson's done it very
elegantly i'm bound to say but
to you to the the meat of your point it
seems to me just as an observer of this
that
there has to be something to hide for
people to behave so evasively i mean
these are
people who are absolutely mastery at
public relations in fact it's really
their chief skill
and particularly good at getting the
line of the day straight and getting
everyone saying the same thing
in sync when that breaks down as it's
been doing
you have to realize or sorry you have to
realize you have to
you're entitled to make the presumption
and there's something they don't want
you to know and that's the presumption
i'm operating on now malcolm pearce of
durham connecticut uh
dear distinguished british cousins uh
the american print and television press
keep telling us how smart the clintons
are yet being smart and having good
judgment aren't necessarily one of the
same
how do liberal and conservative brothers
from across the pond size up the
american first family after a year in
office what kind of grade would you give
him
i'd i think they've done rather
disturbingly well
because what they're very good at is
running a campaign and what's the
president what the clinton presidency is
is the 1996 campaign
rather than the first clinton presidency
what would you say
i hate to agree but i think that's about
right um i mean i
i i say it again i think it's it is the
extension of the bush quail regime los
angeles you're next
yeah i'd just like to quickly say to um
uh questions for peter but i would just
like to say to
christopher hitchens that it's true
there isn't a lot of expression of
his point of view uh in the media and
it's too bad because i think more people
would vote
if there was a more of an expression of
his point of view because i think
the fact people don't vote is partly a
reaction that there isn't
diversity but the question to peter
hitchens
is that um he was talking about the cold
war
and the fact that the soviet union was
an evil empire because of their
their nuclear uh problems i would like
to point out that uh
america tested radiation on its own
population and conducted in
numerous atrocities with nuclear energy
and nuclear weapons
i think to look at one side in the cold
war and call one side an evil empire
is a little naive um well i have to
disagree with you there i i spent two
and a half years in the soviet union and
among the places i visited
was the area in kazakhstan where the
soviet union conducted its nuclear tests
not just the occasional individual
injected a little bit of plutonium but
entire villages
exposed without their knowledge to
plutonium by an immensely cynical regime
political prisoners put on construction
detail on radioactive
sites the whole system so different
from america so difficult for you to
comprehend that
you might think they were equivalent
it's it is
a difference in quality so deep that is
almost impossible to express
and it's certainly impossible to compare
the two i think it's pretty easy to
comprehend though because
even if you didn't know this about the
soviet union
uh because i think it's i regard as
proof that the inhabitants of the
marshall islands were used as guinea
pigs for american nuclear tests and
british ones too in the pacific
the french certainly used the
polynesians as
experimental subjects and more than that
of the inhabitants of hiroshima and
nagasaki were subjected to
um to experiment in the electronic
testing where everybody it's now been
absolutely conclusively demonstrated the
motive for that was not short in the war
all the truman papers are out now
everybody knows that cover story was for
the was for the birds
there was an attempt to see if the damn
thing worked and to frighten the
russians and use the japanese as um
as guinea pigs on any given day what's
the first newspaper you'll pick up and
read
actually the washington times because
it's it's has a
a an opposition stance to to the
government in
washington which i enjoy and which is
much more like
a mourning with the british papers where
you start with a massive criticism of
the government and embarrassing scandals
mr hutchins uh i i find it so difficult
to give my my dime to the
coffers of the reverend moon but i do
read the washington times but i don't
start with but
first i start with the new york times i
guess alas
lack a day but i do i have to lancaster
pennsylvania
good morning gentlemen um this question
is for
christopher please i'd like to know if
he would ever
uh try to interview ramona africa since
may 15th is coming up and a move
in philadelphia was similar to the waco
situation
and uh number two is how does he feel
that the
south african thing is going to play out
with the zulu and the right conservative
with the mandela thing thank you very
much and have a safe day
thank you um well there is a wonderful
book by a man i greatly admire
african-american writer called john
edgar weidman called philadelphia fire
about the the extraordinary events um in
philadelphia the bombing out of the move
commune it hadn't occurred to me to go
and observe the anniversary but i mean
now you
now you mention it it might also be very
interesting i'll give it my best thought
um i love philadelphia anyway every
excuse to go there
as to south africa i've always been an
optimist um
what do you think of what might have
happened if it wasn't for the existence
of the african national congress
and nelson mandela of of the race war in
which the country would long since have
been plunged it would have been far
worse than the congo
and when you think of how narrowly
they've escaped that fate and embarked
on the alternative
it's impossible not to be really
somewhat uplifted i look forward to
the anc winning a clear majority which i
think it would have done even if the
extreme right and the zulu tribalists
have not backed down
and i look forward to the great moment
when nelson mandela will cast his first
vote the first vote of his life
and uh in that same election will become
president i think that's a wonderful
wonderful outcome sorry to interrupt but
it's sorry it's amazing to hear you say
that
that they've avoided a race war the fact
is there is at present a race war taking
place in south africa
and the the coverage which was enormous
during the last
years of the apartheid regime has fallen
away
and if you if you actually saw now what
was going on the amount
of racial killing between hozer and zulu
you would be horrified and that may well
prefigure a far worse
civil war once the anc is still a lot
better than it was going to be or than
it could have been
and it's not yes cnc will be able to
control it fort myers florida last call
for our hitchens brothers go ahead
please
yes i wanted to bring up uh bill
clinton's uh
mentor and and professor at georgetown
university
uh mr clinton mentioned at the
acceptance speech of the democratic
nomination in the speech he said as a
teenager
i heard john kennedy summon to
citizenship
and then as a student at georgetown i
heard that cole
clarified by professor named carl
quigley now carl quigley
wrote a book in 1966 1300 pages
published by the macmillan company and
throughout the book
he refers to the to the council on
foreign relations he refers to it as the
secret
and semi-secret and semi-secret group
and everybody
in almost everybody and bill clinton's
administration
is a member of the of the cfr all right
thanks
i think this is someone who worries
about the trilateral commission a lot
um it's a pity we have to end on it
there's a fax here from cleo rosebud
zoots of of rainbow california who do i
bill for the loss of a 15
birthday dinner c-span or the american
conservative union
switching channels from ads during the
olympic opening ceremony beauty art
music honor a plea to stop the killing
in bosnia
i happened upon c-span and david crock
of the american spittoon
the the exposure to his right-wing
invective caused oral emesis
that right that's right you're a
linguist uh yes
yeah and required large doses of e g h
free milk and ginger snaps i associate
christopher hitchens one of if not the
most brilliant thinkers
social analysts writers in the u.s with
the nation a magazine published since
1865 they
ticked off that over the weekend we
associated with vanity fair instead of
the nation
all weeks he spent his announcer's
appearance on events in the news stating
that he
is with vanity fair a pay on to
consumerism
political gossip and quasi tabloid
reportage why
please ask him to comment that's it
that's the last fact for you sir
how of course i can only look like a
toady if i'd say how wonderful my
employers are but as it happens i think
vancouver has a very serious magazine if
you buy the current number
a the piece on the chops is very
interesting b there's a brilliant
article
on the menendez trial and the
implications for justice
of that trial in california the great
piece by me or not of the north
there's a fantastically interesting
interview by my friend annie bardar with
fidel castro first one he's given to an
american reporter for a long time
this is not the glitz that people take
it for um and it's very cleverly and
carefully edited
fact-checked lawyered it's a pleasure to
be edited uh
the magazine um believe me i would say
this if they weren't paying me
your parents uh were there was there a
conservative and a liberal in the
hitchens home i wouldn't say so no it
was
was very conservative indeed and remar
a little more um compassionate i think
the world would probably be
um perhaps where do you think uh your
brother christopher your older brother
christopher got his views
i've often wondered i genuinely don't
know
it's not in the genes at any rate you
can get
to educate yourself out of genes like
that believe me you can get the
international
express now by writing uh i guess it's
speed of pecs or something like that
3502 48th avenue long island city new
york
for 130 a year you can get international
express
every week with every cent university of
york graduate
peter hitchens been in this country for
the last six months representing the
london daily express as washington
correspondent
has been with the paper for 17 years
prior to coming to the united states was
in moscow
originally was born in malta and grew up
with his brother his
brother two years older than him
christopher hitchens columnist for
vanity fair and the nation
he's been with the nation since 1978 as
a graduate of oxford
originally from portsmouth hampshire
england and we thank you
both for joining us thank you thank you
rod maybe we'll do this again sometime
if you have time and
thanks to our audience have a good week